The head of this corporation walks in
and he looks at me and says, hello
doctor shopper, where's your team?
And I said,
so I work alone in country.
I'm the only person who reaches
out to kids. And he sat down.
He did not say anything for the whole
minute. He looked at me and said,
she'll buy 500,000 children
under five are going blind.
You just one goal. You just one
person. How many places will you visit?
You're never going to get this done.
He stood up and walked away.
I was actually think he was
coming back. Um, he didn't.
If he went back and met with that guy
again, what would you tell him? Thank you.
I caught,
I was afraid of snakes.
The side of the beacon completely
remove their skin really freaked me out.
BEMIS origin is the top most that you
could achieve. Once you're in medicine,
you literally mean a lot of money.
I mean,
that's the word that most people be use.
So when I decided to leave surgery
and get into public health,
a lot of my peers ridiculed me and me.
Temporary insanity. I remember
one of my friends, yeah,
there for a reason. They're there
to tell you that it's not possible,
but it's not possible for them.
I lost all of my friends during that time.
One of my things,
why am I afraid of snakes?
The snake is able to let go of its
skin and start afresh every year.
Maybe I should also try and do that.
There is a difference between clinical
medicine and preventative medicine.
In clinical medicine,
a patient goes to a doctor when there
is something wrong in preventative
medicine,
I will go to a patient even before
they know that something is wrong.
So a very early on, I remember
visiting a brick field in Kolkata.
There were these five kids
among 20 I would already blind.
They had the white spots on the cornea
and that shocked me to the core. I had
never even heard of such a thing before.
There was no documentation of so many
children being blind in the same place.
When a child goes blind because
of vitamin E deficiency,
the transparent part of the eye, which
is called the cornea, literally males,
because there's not enough vitamin E
to hold the corneal structure together.
And I remember this one kid who was
three years old and I kept looking at the
face trying to catch
a glimpse of her eyes,
but she kept shying away because I
think she was being bullied by the other
kids.
I just wanted to check with
you about the shipping up. Now
I'm going to a birthday shit, but
rather the unofficial, uh, uh,
employee of whatever she does,
I always run around and know
she's in Parabola to help her out.
She gone, uh, see anyone in bean.
That's why she's able to do a job.
So you want it to be a
doctor since forever.
Okay.
How far do was blame? So we understand
what blindness is all about. For us,
it's a pretty emotional thing.
So for a child who hasn't even seen
the world and unable to do it, it,
it depends a lot.
So all of these four graphs
have been shot by my dad.
He used to be a photographer and
this is what he did every weekend.
Bring other camera and make me photos.
As you can see,
I'm very comfortable
in front of the camera.
I think it was trying to go for the jail.
Look,
I always have the sense of I
couldn't prevent his blindness,
but to my current work,
I have an opportunity to prevent
blindness in someone else.
However,
it's just the fact that these children
are located in such hard to reach areas.
It could be an urban slump.
They could be migrants who have just
come into a city and not daunted by the
local health authorities.
We knew that there was a problem
and we knew what the solution was.
Oh,
it's a simple intervention.
Two capsules a year of high dose vitamin
A can prevent blindness in children
under five. So we had two dots, but
we didn't know how to connect them.
Essentially, if I knew that the
challenge is in, in dry food,
I go to write book, uh, reached
500 kids over day with vitamin E
and then I come back.
Then I knew of another place in
Orissa and the tribal belts over Resa.
We'd each out over them support thousand
kids under five and then again come
back.
Every time I went out to a new area, I
will speak to them about the intervention.
They would think about it and
then they would get back saying
it was just me going to a new area and
coming back maybe and shorting one doors,
but that wouldn't really help.
We needed someone to keep doing this
program again and again and again do the
child was five years of age.
I was talking to the auto guy,
I was talking to taxi drivers,
people on the plane,
people in the washroom and most of them
would take the card, look at it and say,
interesting,
we get back to you
and it's tough.
It's tough because even right now I know
that kids in some of the states where
you're not getting the Dominik.
Okay,
and you can do only so much.
Okay.
I was visiting a deaf and mute partner.
There were these five zero to put into
your or speak and they were being taught
how to make the tongues and the to make
a sound and there was this young girl,
the teacher would repeat a different sound
every time and she would just keep on
saying, the Dj would say
far and she would say, God,
the Dj would say bar and she would say,
just repeat the same sound
again and again and again,
but she was doing it with so much
enthusiasm and so much domination.
I couldn't stop myself
from crying for 15 minutes.
Shaper, how dare you feel
disheartened by one failure?
How dare you look at this girl,
she's five she can't speak.
She cannot sure and yet look at the
enthusiasm in which he's trying to know.
This was not something I was
going to be able to do a loan.
I think not many people
know about the angry shaper,
how angry she can get funds
a valuation writing. She,
I don't know what the incident was,
but she got angry and she
just smashed a window pane.
Just mash it with the bare hands.
[inaudible].
She wanted to learn martial arts.
My father never allowed it.
He was always updates.
You would get some of that.
Okay.
One of my friends had a friend who
knew off a mother's group in northern.
I had not even heard of
Nagaland at that point of time.
Yeah.
[inaudible] is the most eastern
steeped in the country of India.
It borders with Myanmar.
Yeah.
There's no more durable wrote
with some of the villages.
They literally had to walk up to a
few villages for three days. Even.
You were initially very apprehensive,
but we train them within month and we
have been preaching about 60 to 70,000
children under five now.
For the past seven years,
these weren't our doctors or even
medical workers. It was a mother's group.
All women in the most
remote part of the country.
That was a surprise. And then from then
on, things when you started speeding up,
identifying local volunteers who would
take the responsibility of saying,
yes,
we will sustain the program going forward.
If you give us the proper tools in
terms of training, in terms of medicine,
we will take it.
And so more people joining this
mission is actually what was important.
Without whom we would not have been able
to reach the number of children we are
reaching right now and give reaching
12.5 million children in India right now.
I think all of us have our stories.
We just need to own up to our story.
Why did I have to go through this pain
of seeing my most beloved person go
through blindness?
I think that thing was meant, said,
I could understand my colleagues.
You do get an understanding
of why it's happening,
why it's you now I do
understand why it's me.
That's my story.
Thank you for watching.
Uh,
this piece about Dr Shilpa in India
and we made this for giving me.
That's right.
Not only to highlight Dr Chopra and
the amazing work that she's doing,
but also to raise awareness for another
organization called Doctors Without
Borders.
They go where no other groups go.
They'll respond to natural disasters,
a war victims,
even disease doctors,
nurses, logistical experts.
Over 30,000 of them in 60 different
countries. I would just stop man.
What an incredible opportunity.
We have a,
especially during this holiday season to
raise awareness and money for a really
worthy cause and we want to just encourage
all of the jubilee leavers out there,
uh, to give. This will continue to,
to be an opportunity for you guys to give
well until the new year watching. Um,
so whether it's $1 or $5,
definitely one encourage you guys to give.
The other cool thing is when you donate,
your donation will be matched.
So when you get $5, that's doctors
without borders will get $10.
Thank you guys for hanging around and
thank you for letting us do what we do in
highlighting great people in great stories
and we hopefully we can do a lot more
stick around. We have a lot more videos
for you guys that are good stuff.
So we'll see you next time.